the real [ __ ] would be organizing people
and getting people that have differing
views to unite not even that
[ __ ] you dude
that would be it's kind of [ __ ] up up
here huh you know the viewers can't see
but there's a bunch of crazy [ __ ] on the
ceiling this office is a mess
[Music]
I don't know if you guys seen this but
uh a museum in London these climate
protesters through tomato soup at a van
Gogh painting I saw that why they always
do that because I believe in the way
dude you you already don't support this
it's a van Gogh yeah but it's the
[ __ ] climate the planet dude why do
they get him out of here he didn't do
nothing yeah he didn't eat soup
bro bro [ __ ] these [ __ ]
whoa dude why the people in the back
what what what part of uh what country
is this London they should what do they
do on lipstick they're eating a Twix
they should do it they're gonna do a
speech I love Twix are they getting with
a can of soup
how do they get so close to the painting
do they super glue their hands yeah they
glue their hands stick it to the wall so
it can't be moved that's so [ __ ] dumb
life life more than food dude look at
that guy's face detection of a planet
oh that's a dude
it's a day man then why did you [ __ ]
throw it on the painting like if someone
came up and just landed like three good
body shots on both of them I would laugh
so hard and I would be like they deserve
that [ __ ]
and they're just hanging they're just
hanging because the super glue they're
just like it's just like cut the van
Gogh and like the super glue is gonna
like really make their hands stick to
the wall for that long yeah dude their
skin is just gonna come off dude that's
a good super glue commercial
it's just crazy glue crazy because oh no
wait where'd they say how people
couldn't afford to have kids but then
they're like throwing soup on a painting
like they could have just donated that
can that's not the point shut up can
you're [ __ ] with their fight bro it's
a can of soup you don't see yourself
over there because of the rising
inflation from the decisions being made
in you know the UK that's what they're
protesting that some families can't even
afford to eat or whatever but like I'll
say this if uh if they had an American
accent and they deliver that speech I
would have stopped listening like hey
you know what you're right a little bit
yeah you're right you're right because
they're British I was like oh it's
actually pretty good it's a good speech
you're like well it's just easy on the
ears yeah yeah yeah what is more
important
I was like it does sound more important
yeah Lord
of Chinese oh damn they're Vietnamese
Vietnamese and did that I'd listen
harder he wouldn't have questioned the
[ __ ] tin suit part of it like I would
have just been laughing wow they just
throw fur yeah I think people from
Vietnam would never do something what is
more important
then it would sound mad philosophical
God damn I never thought about this
this guy's a philosopher sitting there
was hand glued to the wall so stupid a
funny detail is that they really did so
the dad the painting didn't get damaged
yeah there's glass on it yeah and they
and they actually these protesters made
sure that they didn't really want they
didn't actually want to damage the paint
oh okay okay okay they should have said
that at the beginning well they do go up
to them be like there is glass we're
good dude I was upset what's your ideal
thing that they say before they're like
don't worry there's glass it's not gonna
damage and then they do it I love the
first guy that's like oh
that was me that was me in my head I was
like whoa what the [ __ ] yeah it's [ __ ]
up that was a lot that one guy was
tripping he didn't know that he did not
know there was glasses we were tripping
I was tripping too he's like the guide
of Married With Children audience like
whoa
naughties yeah just starting to have a
chill day at the Museum yeah
I'm still waiting for it to be a [ __ ]
crazy blue commercial it works I mean
we're talking about it right now yeah
but are we changing anything about our
way of life I'm not gonna have tomato
soup today yeah because we're one Ken we
also realized that all advertisements
even in America need to not be an
English American access yes no that's
true yeah they want to sell something
they got to speak with some [ __ ] easy
on the ears tone or Vietnamese and if
villains want to be more nefarious same
deal so the protest was not for oil it
was for Rising I think it was both okay
yeah it was all the above because they
were I believe there's like multiple
there were multiple instances of this
like going on so they have like an
agenda they're trying to push and trying
to get some action taken but again I
don't think there's any real like
solutions that are actually being well
let's at least for our duty and
responsibility is as Society to get
straight what was the true motive so
that even if we don't agree but we
repeat it at least their message has
been heard yeah they don't want they
don't want uh
oil like money being spent on oil
extraction oh get the [ __ ] out of here
dude you're not gonna stop that you
can't stop that it's way bigger than you
dude let's let's
we'll judge it right afterwards hear the
whole message okay so they don't want
oil something I'm not an oil man it's
just it's just everyone loves oil and I
see that not the sea turtles bro and and
they're against inflation who isn't [ __ ]
dude everyone's against it we can agree
with them we're on against them but
people think like this is some new [ __ ]
this happens every [ __ ] like it might
be new to them they look like 16.
exactly so their heart's in the right
place but it's just like Hey we're all
mad too dude but we gotta [ __ ] play
balls okay let's just be patient what
else they got those are those are the
main things
that's it they're called just stop oil
let's give up next message just give up
just give up dude take the dick in the
ass make more money make more money and
and find your way in the oils again but
nice accidents Find Your Way in the
Oilers game
matter and Change it from the inside
yeah be a [ __ ] you wanted to make
change be a VP and then you realize oh
it's life is good at the top yeah
[Laughter]
[ __ ] everyone else that's what's gonna
Nick is making there he's making them
throw the [ __ ] tomato soup bro like
people like me he's inspiring them to
change their perspective get yours
because no one's looking after you
[ __ ]
you better guess yours young kids
man I'm a capitalist I was gonna buy
that van Gogh
because we already know how like it's
somewhere out there there are some some
guy in in stem research or in like
science and he's studying to find a
better energy source and he's doing all
these [ __ ] like oh yeah he or she is
working really hard to find a
substitution yeah and then there's
people that are just like well just stop
what should it's just young kids they're
just young yeah like when you're young
you're just you don't you don't think
[ __ ] though you're just mad and
emotional you throw [ __ ] tomato soup
and homie that was there that didn't say
anything he's trying to hook up he's
trying to get it okay
yeah I'm like dude I'm not trying to
glue my [ __ ] dude that's dumb and after
they kick him out he's gonna be like
wasn't that so crazy we just did that
want to get dinner yeah yeah get out of
here what a rush
that's what I think is crazy there's
people that are actively studying and
getting like phds to try to fix this
problem and then there's this yeah yeah
but you give the guy from PhD are like
you know we should just do this instead
when it finally changes where's the
credit gonna go really yeah but the
people's actually trying to fix the
problem they're not loud enough that's
why there's these yeah because they're
nerds yeah speak up Ken
people also just fight amongst each
other over the dumbest [ __ ] like if the
real [ __ ] would be organizing people and
getting people that have differing views
to unite not even that [ __ ] you dude
he's like dude people fight about the
dumbest [ __ ] that would be it's kind of
[ __ ] up up here huh you know the
viewers can't see but there's a bunch of
crazy [ __ ] on the ceiling this office is
a mess
this one works for Exxon 100 yeah he has
to dude yeah he's got a [ __ ] motor
oil sign above oh yeah dude
Texaco baby number one brand in the
world it says Sinclair Dino
one but but like isn't it like Exxon on
those guys they make a lot of [ __ ] they
probably make it's like the number one
industry in like the US and you think
they eat tomato soup
why not they're too rich for that [ __ ] I
think that does suck too is the
collateral damage on a van Gogh yeah or
like uh anything that's like not related
yeah no one can bring in their lunch to
this Museum anymore yeah exactly right
nope now the security has been
heightened oh sandwiches Liberties get
taken away yeah that's when you walk
into a spot you don't know what the
context is but it just says [ __ ] like no
super glue allowed yeah yeah you're like
why
why durian at the airport why these are
the people that like the same like the
shoe bomber like we can't bring yeah
take your shoes off at the airport
because one [ __ ] was like a bomb in
my shoe that is ladies yeah and it
wasn't even successful like would you
guys be upset if they began racial
profiling at museums where they would
stop every white person or people with
colored hair yeah yeah
if you run a museum in your racial
profiling which ethnic group are you
like I have no problems letting these
people in for sure you can come all day
you can come I don't know man it's hard
to be every group has their their people
that [ __ ] up museums yeah it's just
different ways Asians Asians take
pictures and snapping constantly even
though it says no flash photography
real painful nemesh the same
real problem over here we have a [ __ ]
epidemic they got that thing with the
Chinese tourists like fell over the rope
and tore the [ __ ] painting because he
was clumsy yeah so clumsy dude geez
that's just the tourists not Chinese
it's different can we just stick to the
facts here all right put the hex down
man
the real problem here huh oh you gotta
be Jackie Chan X gang and [ __ ]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign